ciao a tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
video sono pavilio ci giochiamo a scrive
il punto io con stef e fede tra l'altro
oggi c'è una prova particolare perché
step ha creato 15 no quanto 17 17 17
cose da indovinare io e ferrell e
dovremo disegnare deve far indovinare
all'altro step non so cosa hai creato
spero non cose difficili perché io
disegno come un cane però proviamo cile
mio zio magari evangelisti traversa sono
usciti tre ore allora è no niente
mettete la scelta lui gli open system
lunghezza ok allora avete un dvd nulla
ma dove mangiare questa allora questo
meno rischi nè che vi vediamo figurati
indovinarlo a questo è un omino perché
quello che pensavo non lo so aiutami
perché voglio trovare molto triste ok 12
molto triste ma non può essere ci sei
non ci stanno i soldi dai aver
monetizzato mani noti come voglia di
segnare al port ghalib impossibile come
dovevi scegliere il fatto di cadere vita
è troppo bella per ora non si può
arrivare
non ci posso arrivare alla devi fare un
omino e per farlo capire a lui deve
essere terribile allora aspetta ne
facciamo due ok ok lander no sono due
omini domini allora uno e questo è che
ti fa le cuffie perché è questa e
l'amico di quello che dietro è iscritto
pietro angolo sul mio p ospito davvero
la mente ancora spigolo ma dai
eroico cielo sparate però anche vita
perché veramente ricorda di aver legato
e figura di tale che se veramente strana
però che lo ri potercela fare allora
skin di minecraft ero brain che bella
era un drive aveva un po uno zombie
capito proprio questo labili e ho detto
quindi ero vera non può essere zombie
sono stati molto gravi bene allora ok si
deve ingegnare di brutto le a pagamento
per esempio chi sommossa dai se non si
arrivi ti sentirai male per tutta la
folla a gombola red dragon ball è giusto
dopo l'idea è stata io ma che finora non
erano scudo beh allora perché ora esatto
la rete un destro non si faccia che la
penna prepara a uk però poco sheen
ironica non ci credo mi mettete
imballate nota è bellissimo di fatto
benissimo però petra new che pinocchio
più o meno la signora papi j
non ci credete ho indovinato subito 5
lettera g domani sono un fenomeno
gravissimo e bio lui lo indovina a chi
tocca
spero non a me tocca a te mamma mia
ragazzi
ok cielo macori di a istituti giura che
miei confusa anche se gli altri ceo che
cos'è sa unire al posto di capelli
appunto chi è che lo capisco non ci
arrivo di anch'io non è colpa tua
l'hai fatta tu pensa te mi confido
ancora di più il mio dio ragazzi allora
aspetta uno scrittore è uno scrittore
sta vivendo un biglietto e c'è una
bandiera sarà perché sia una bandiera
certo certo certo certo
dovevi farlo arancione cavolo arancione
quello e no mai la pelle che sono sicuro
che non si faccia la bandiera americana
maceri d'alta è uguale alla faccia di
quel colore è certo come faceva parla
tra lettera è staccata una allora
facciamo così pensate lo faccia viva il
maledetto bello è lei a per in staccata
una tiratura è ok ma cosa gira cos'è per
in via confuso sapido e molto meno
complicato di così è il giro della morte
per la china a punti a 5 insomma
selvaggio legale perché essi stessi
sentimenti subito ma oggi credo bene
penso a ritornare che cosa ha trovato
ben bene come vanno aggiunti i
bruttissimi
come faccio a fare prete se la vuoi fare
da eco ma faccio madonna la gamma una
roba un po più lunga
facciamo così ok allora arrivarci sia
per punti diver punti
il pcc questo è un codino che i due
possano capire chi è calcoli non conosco
nessuno col codino è poi facciamo tipo
do fare un tratto distintivo per far
capire cosa facciamo
non riesco a farlo dove troppo difficili
lo so allora draga di mario stiamo
parlando di una cosa vedere la
coincidenza è bellissima come faccio a
farlo capire la vado a me cosa faccia
qua che storto
ho già detto ciccio maker
non ci sono però il colore la giusta era
così forte che cavolo e lo fa nulla ma
allora allora mi devo preoccupare
questa è un'opera d'arte è lunghissima
ma i ragazzi le cose non lo capisco non
vi giuro che non ho capi è una tavola e
una tavola stavamo porno gay
ok ok ok a questo punto io continuo a
non capire e neanch'io però verso arriva
però non è male la forchetta di coda è
quella una mano è una mano a finire le
cose pulire in uscita ma li sta pulendo
non so più cosa dirvi che ho sbagliato
ci davano per me è troppo tardi dire gli
altri elementi è impossibile è quello
l'elemento crew penso a te e chi sa
disintegrata ma cos'è la palette
aspirazione ma dai ma perché con 10
sbagliato è ripreso le dure io ho
pensato tipo politici se ne manager a
cera che se si vuol dire c'era che sono
a pulire raga proporrei un round solo
normativa che mai
bellissimo però aspiratrice amori con 2
cibo e che bello ok preoccupato molto
perché ho problemi a fare i cerchi ma
perché soprattutto fai solo persone due
incredibili capito quello che eri
specializzato depressione dai dai dai
dai brut no non sono mai non saprei come
farlo fini così ragazzi è una persona
come come questa persona come disperato
è grande ma si vede che già lamiere
nieto come era con le braccia in alto
disperato che stava cessavano albero
quercia e acero ma come coronamento
sai qual è esattamente il colore
dell'autunno esalti complimenti degli
occhiali occhiali cappelli temono
scienziato non può essere un agente a
madonna che harry potter ma così ma
guerri animalista non è un signore ma in
realtà però non so bene ma dobbiamo dire
si riuniva di star che sono lì è
sinonimo allora non ci arriva
sì perché visto che rolando malamente ha
chiaramente questo grande si capisce più
in lui
vergognati vediamo se così fare faceva
molto venuto subito genio quando ok
questo è difficile preparare le tre
parole mar di non ci credono ma devo
fare la prima è una cagata e ha scritto
per dire una cagata era giusto ma devo
fare la persona che fumino ceco non
bastavano i mal di mare con il mare
basta nome di stream animale mar divario
ragazzino la nota ve lo giuro non me lo
dà di mare
che problemi ragazzi io ringrazio te
febbre per questa meravigliosa tecnica
di disegno che non insegnato lei al
polso video e schede vero grande
estinzione di siete anche al mio viaggio
da fare la campanella perdi mai
ragionati condivido che escono civile
da ragazzo
[Musica]